Disney may be a major studio, but it started
small, which meant its animators had to bring
people, animals, and magical creatures to
life better than any one.
When they did just that - and didn't have
the budget to bankroll million-dollar movies
- the animators decided NOT to start from
scratch.
Instead, they traced over animation that had
already been released.
And if you think it's just a case of copying
a handful of frames, we've got a surprise
for you!
Here are Screen Rant's 5 Recycled Movie Scenes
In Disney Films.
Robin Hood
Nobody throws a party like Robin and his Merry
Men, and a good party means plenty of dancing.
Over the years, Disney's animators had delivered
more than a few musical sequences in a ton
of films, and decided to make Robin Hood into
something of a highlight reel.
Maid Marian gets her moves from Snow White
over three decades earlier, with a few dashes
of Duchess from The Aristocats just to be
safe.
Lady Kluck and Little John do their best impression
of Baloo and King Louie from The Jungle Book,
showing that dance moves don't always change
with the times.
The Jungle Book
It's no secret that animators tend to look
at their own pets when designing animals or
magical beasts, but man's best friend takes
the cake in Disney films.
That means the animators knew they could use
puppies from 101 Dalmatians as the basis for
their wolf pups in The Jungle Book.
But even more time was spent turning Arthur's
slobbering dogs from the Sword in the Stone
into Mowgli's grown-up brothers and sisters.
Since dogs aren't exactly skilled at hiding
their feelings, we can probably let this one
slide.
The Sword in The Stone
Some movies can take bits of animation here
or there, but where do you draw the line between
saving time, and just skipping work?
Disney couldn't always decide, if The Sword
in the Stone is anything to go by.
When the movie's climax called for an epic
jousting match, the animators decided to check
the archives for footage to fit.
They found it in the Disney Classic "The Truth
About Mother Goose."
And by found it, we mean copied it completely,
shot for shot.
The Many Adventures of Winnie The Pooh
When Disney decided to lump together smaller
featurettes starring Winnie the Pooh into
one theatrical release, they ran into a bit
of a problem: the collection, released as
The Many Adventures of Winnie the Pooh, didn't
have an ending.
But with some fast-thinking, and even faster
hands, they came up with a solution.
The answer was to craft a new ending starring
Winnie and his owner, Christopher Robin.
The pair's farewell loses some of its magic
when you realize it's a direct tracing of
an entire sequence from The Jungle Book.
Apparently, a love of bears wasn't all that
Mowgli and Christopher Robin had in common.
Beauty & The Beast
It was the evil witch Maleficent who made
sure that Sleeping Beauty's 16th birthday
wouldn't be a happy one, sending her (and
the entire kingdom with her) into a deep sleep.
It all worked out in the end, when Prince
Phillip woke her with true love's kiss, and
the pair announced their love with a dance
so perfect, it sent them into the clouds.
There's no way to top a dance like that, so
when animators had to match it with Beauty
& The Beast thirty years later, they didn't
even try.
They simply traced Beauty and the now-human
Beast over the couple, and assumed fans wouldn't
mind seeing a true love's waltz all over again.
Those are the bits of recycled Disney footage
that caught our eye, but what other scenes
or characters have always stuck out to you?
Be sure to name them in the comments, and
click on subscribe for more great videos like
this one!